hello and welcome to delta in the
following video i will show you how
easy and uncomplicated you can evaluate your data
directly online with the app
for this you go to the day.de page
and click on the statistics
calculator
then you click on table teachers and
add your own  data in this
table 1
i simply use the example
and the variables that you
want to evaluate appear below is
important that you make sure that
the names of your variables are in the first row in
these tabs you will now find the
methods you need  to evaluate
your data in the first tab you can evaluate your data in
depth the script you can, for
example, output the mean value or the
standard
deviation or you can create frequency tables
and cross tables
the next day you can carry out a large number
of hypothesis tests
datatec helps  you can find the right
test here
an example you have in your  he survey
men and women
asked about their salary now you want to know whether
men and women differ in terms of
salary
to find out you want to find out the
variable income and gender from
datatec knows which test is suitable for your question
and suggests the
independent test  before the
requirements for the test for
independent samples are not met
you can also calculate the non-parametric
test den man holt new test of
course you can also use the app
to calculate many other hypotheses test
if you click a nominal
variable with more than two values
e.g  a
variant analysis is automatically calculated for the
location, i.e. datatec always presented the appropriate test
depending on which variable you select
which methods there are of course
you can also easily
calculate a correlation analysis with data hat a
regression analysis a main component
analysis and a cluster analysis like that  i.e  this
was a first overview of
the possibilities of datatec for each of
the methods that you can calculate. you can
find detailed tutorials here under tutorials,
e.g. for the perpetrator
, for independent spot checks or for
the variance analysis or the correlation analysis, you are welcome to visit
our youtube
channel  there you will find many videos
explaining datatec and generally
useful information about
statistical data evaluation and now
i wish you a lot of fun with data tab